Okay, welcome everybody to another Zoom call and get if you have questions you can chant them in.
Please make every effort when you do send in your questions to send them in as early as possible.
You know, the closer we get to four o'clock, the less chance on certain days for sure that I will even get them into the call.
I always look at the members home page for new information.
What are the things that you'll see on the members home page because I've always added stuff to the courses. I always added stuff to the member page.
What are the new things that you've been on the new member home page lately.
Is this information about getting a glucometer.
And about testing how to test your blood using a glucometer, you can buy one on Amazon here.
And to take it fast, you can download the chart right here that I created for you to keep track of your blood glucose how to test it and why you want to get your blood glucose down.
Even if your cancer isn't completely fed by glucose glycolysis, every cell uses glycolysis to grow into function to make ATP.
So there isn't a cancer that doesn't use glucose to some degree.
So eating your glucose levels lower is beneficial for everybody with cancer, it's beneficial with everybody.
If you don't have cancer, so getting your glucose levels down would be great. The goal is 75 or below.
If you're doing a ketogenic diet, your goal is to get it even lower than that.
If you are doing a ketogenic diet, I don't know if anybody on this balls doing a ketogenic diet, but even if you're not on a keto like diet, your goal is still to try to get your glucose as low as possible.
Now some of you might go, oh my gosh, my doesn't ever get below 90. Well, you just keep working on it.
Keep watching your diet to do that. Make sure you look at the different courses, make sure you look at the blog posts.
And let's see, this was a question from last time.
So first question, I said to my lab student, my two of our cars have spiked any suggestions. Yes, I saw those last night. Thank you for setting those.
I will be starting on mistletoe next week, but my local oncologist wants to be on eyebrows.
One more month before he changes anything, even with those changes in two markers, I can't believe he isn't willing to make changes. I would like to do another cheek swam.
There's some other things that I've been researching for you. So if you can set it another cheek swam, that would be wonderful.
Coffee and a daily, seven days per week for about a year, though, is it possible to develop a sensitivity to caffeine?
So the answer to that is yes, you can.
By fitness band recently noted high heart rate in the evening after doing a coffee at a well, you will, if you absorb some caffeine, which you typically will, when you do a coffee at a well,
you can raise your heart rate, 150 plus beats per minute. That to me is too high. I also reduced my thyroid bed.
I like to see your thyroid labs. If you have them, should I stop? Enemies are continue with less coffee. I would just switch to
two and
two.
your fitness band. So this fitness band I think you're talking about is those things that you
wear and you can measure your heart rate and stuff like that. I know some of you looked at fitness
band and remember that 80s punk band but no that's not what he's talking about. So yeah I would change
it. I would go last coffee. I would just change it to chamomile to e-enema and that's that's
what I would do. Dosage for panic here with prostate cancer. Dosage for panic here with prostate
cancer. I would do one pack. So if you're getting the panic here in the boxes and there's three packs,
one gram each each packet. Do one pack a day start with four days on three days off four days on
three days off. You could put it in your smoothie. You could mix it straight but it's better to throw
it in your smoothie or your greens or something like that and it's fairly tasteless. Do four days on
three days off. That's what I would do for prostate cancer. I was reading three easy steps to
clear histamine from your body. That's not an article from me but this person says towards the end
of the article it discusses how to treat histamine intolerance. Point three says it's important to find
the root cause of the histamine intolerance other than genetics. How do you find a root cause
under the genetics of my histamine intolerance? Histamines are a driver of my breast cancer.
So we're talking about two different things. So if a person has excess histamine in their body,
there's multiple possible reasons. Number one is that they have genetic defects so they don't
clear histamine very well and you can't fix those genetic defects. So you're just using things like
corset to the other things to help pull the histamine out of your body. Number two, you can have
subinflammatory process that's causing a histamine increase. That's what I think author of this article
is talking about is find the root cause of the histamine intolerance. You can't find the cause of
the histamine intolerance. I think what they mean is find what's causing the histamine increase.
What's causing the excess histamine. So histamine is an inflammatory marker that stimulates
an immune attack in the presence of some something in your body that shouldn't be in your body.
So in the case of you have a pathogen in your body, you will stimulate a histamine attack to
try to clear that out of your body. It's your initial immune response to a toxin, to a poison,
to a pathogen. If it just continues to ramp and your cells continue to make histamine,
now that's an issue. Part of that has to do with genetics. Part of that has to do with a sensitivity.
So let me explain. If my body has created antibodies against a toxin,
let's use an example of the toxin in a mosquito bite. I don't know the name of the toxin that
the mosquito injects into you when it draws your blood out to use for whatever purposes the mosquito
uses your blood for. But whatever toxin it uses, some people, some people go, oh my gosh,
when I get a mosquito bite, I have this huge histamine reaction and I itch like crazy and I swell up.
And other people like I go on the same mosquito infested territory and they don't seem to bother me at all.
And it can be because the mosquitoes don't necessarily land on you and light on you and bite on you
because of your body chemistry. That's a whole other story. But let's say you get just as bit
as somebody else or a bug bites or you could you could extend this to pollen. You could extend this to
poison ivy reaction. You can extend this to other fly reactions and stuff like that. Why are some
people more intolerant to those? Why do some people have a greater histamine reaction to those?
Well, partly it has can be that the that person's body has made antibodies to that toxin.
And because they made antibodies that toxin every time that toxin is present, they fire this huge
immune reaction because they have antibodies. It's no different than if I have antibodies to
gluten, gliantin peptides in gluten. And every time I eat gluten, I fire this reaction. I have this
inflammatory process going on in my gut, in my brain, in my bloodstream and everything else.
It's because I have antibodies to that peptide of food. So if I have created antibodies
inadvertently to something that is a major reason why I have histamine reactions. Now the problem
is is that you can't just make those antibodies go away. Nothing pulls those antibodies out of your
body. Some antibodies literally will stay forever. Like in the case of gluten,
gliantin antibodies, they don't tend to dissipate. Or if you have antibodies to other foods,
if you stay away from that food for a period of time, pretty, you know, many of those foods,
the antibodies dissipate quite quickly. You could do another Cyrex 10 test for food antibodies.
And those are gone. So you don't have sensitivity. So that because you stayed away from that
for a period of time, same thing if you do a Cyrex 11 or 12 test, which tests antibodies
to chemicals in your environment and other pathogens in your environment like mold and things.
If you clear your body of those things, you're not continually exposed to those things,
pretty soon your those antibodies go down and down. You're not going to react to that as much.
So that's how if you really want to find out why I have reactions to different things, I know I have
histamine as a driver of my breast cancer, doing a Cyrex 10 doing a Cyrex 4 to see if you have
antibodies to other foods that are related to gluten. The three X related to gluten and
and other gluten cross-reactants in the Cyrex 4, the Cyrex 10 array 10 is a panel of a whole bunch
of different foods. I think a hundred different foods are so cooked and raw to see if you have antibodies
to that. So if there it if it's anything that has to do with exposure to foods that's increasing
histamines, secondly you could do a Cyrex 11 and a Cyrex 12 that tests for do I have antibodies to
pathogens do I have antibodies to chemicals in my environment. If I have antibodies to those things
and I am exposed to those things every time I'm exposed to those things, I'm going to create more
histamines. So measuring what I should stay away from can be beneficial. So you have more information
on that gladly make an appointment we can figure out what test would be best to order.
Questions about meat and histamines is uncured organic turkey breast okay to eat.
Yes so typically you could you could download the histamine list on our website you could Google a
histamine list of different foods. The older a food is we need if it's if it's a lunch meat and you
if it was you know hooked in a week ago and now it's sitting in the grocery store now you buy it
it's going to have greater histamines in it. If you just bought a turkey and cooked up the turkey
breast and you ate it it's going to have a lot less histamines than if you leave it in the fridge for
a couple more days or you eat it cold it's going to have more histamines in it. So the more aged
the product is it's going to have more histamines. Organic grass-fed nitrate-free meat sticks like
chumps okay to eat. Well they're going to have some more histamines in it. Now your histamine
problem may be much less related to the amount of histamines that you're eating and more related to foods
that you're eating that are creating a histamine reaction like I explained before. So a person can
have issues because they eat foods with a lot of histamines that's less honestly that's less of a
problem. Unless a person's like oh my gosh I have a habit of just eating a whole you know
bowl full of cashews and then a bowl full of strawberries strawberries and those are really good for
me. Well the house I have a lot of histamines in it but if that's not your case and you're eating a
fairly balanced meal and you're not getting foods that are just so concentrated in histamines
then the reason why you might have a histamine issue is because your body's making histamines
because you have antibodies against things that you're exposed to whether it be foodborne products
or pathogens or chemicals. So those are the things that you want to look at. Sometimes when people
have histamine issues they really get hung up on their diet that that's going to solve it and
disdain away from things that have histamine in it may be a little help to a person. It's when they
know they're staying away from this they're only eating this certain food that has very little
histamines on the histamine food list but they actually have antibodies to that food
so every time they eat that food their body is making histamines to deal with it. So I know that
sounds complicated but you know if you can understand that your body makes histamine and you
you're not trying to stop your body from making histamine you're trying to go why is my body
making histamine against a food well it shouldn't unless you have an antibody against that food
or a pathogen unless you have antibodies to that pathogen so for instance if a person has antibodies
to a mosquito the pathogen the chemical in a mosquito bite they're not exposed to mosquitoes they don't
have a histamine reaction the only happening when they're exposed to that chemical hopefully that
helps. Is there a rife program that will boost energy levels really no I would I mean directly
could help energy levels I mean if you're I would think you could run the adrenal program you could
run the thyroid program the pituitary program that might help with energy levels
but just stimulating your your hormones that you're that you know kick in energy which would be
really your adrenals in your pituitary your thyroid would be the things to run
to help with energy with the rife. My previous holistic practitioner said from blood work that I
was pre-diabetic laid on set type one she had me had a couple supplements that were supposed to
help regulate my blood sugar designs for health burberry synergy mitochondrial energy of which I
am no longer taking I did take this diagnosis very seriously since I had not been symptomatic
as far as I do it felt very good while hungry or
uh intermittent fasting or even fasting for several days even while I was a vegan this winter however
I know in the past two to four weeks feel like my metabolism is on hyperdripe and I wake up
depleted and weak and light headed so um understand if you have diabetes you have the inability to get
blood sugar into the cell because of damaged cell membrane receptors talking about um um type two
diabetes if you truly have laid on set type one diabetes then you have antibodies to the
eyelid cells in the pancreas that make insulin so that's a totally different type of diabetes
and really a totally different disease the will manifest from a blood sugar level leading
measuring blood glucose levels with something as simple as a glucometer like this is is elevated blood
glucose the same as diabetes type two so then you have to find out by testing antibody levels
or whether you have antibodies to take your dialysis so that's how you would diagnose
type one diabetes uh if you do have type one or type two diabetes um have it a metabolism in
hyperdripe really I mean it depends on how you're defining the metabolism hyperdripe but uh and
feeling and waking up feeling depleted and weak and light headed really wouldn't be the symptoms
necessarily of diabetes that would be more the symptoms of uh uh waking up depleted and
weak and light headed would be more the symptoms of hypoglycemia and then when you measure your
glucose of the morning you'd have very suppressed glucose levels it takes me a long time in the
morning to get enough food for me to keep the feel better really again that's really not the symptom
diabetes again the way you diagnose diabetes is technically if you have blood glucose levels the
fasting blood glucose levels of more than one incidence of over 125 decilier leaders per
bikerim so on a blood monitoring sugar it'd be over 125 where it says 104 on this
after 10 or 12 hour fast and it has to be more than one instance this morning I crashed in terrible
shaky weekend weakness so that would be signs of hypoglycemia um and that can happen with someone
with diabetes but that happens with somebody with diabetes whether on insulin and they're taking too
much insulin so it's bringing their blood sugar level too low so it's a hypoglycemic
instance in diabetes because of excess use of insulin not monitoring that well enough so um that's
what you want to look for get yourself a glucometer if you don't have one and start measuring your
glucose levels um in the morning that's over and let's go to the home page of the member site and
download that chart and start keeping track of that um I'm supposed to begin chemo next week can you
imagine surviving this I'm very fragile so make sure you monitor that get your blood glucose levels
in your blood levels balanced um as best you possibly can I will be away from home July 19 to August
7 to 6 you're just I take my wife with me uh I will be in hotels I'll be flying from turkey to
Switzerland uh what do you tell the agents yeah it's we've had this question lots of times in the past
it really it really depends on a couple of things if you're doing really well and you're going to go
on a two week vacation you're doing fantastic you could certainly do without your right for two weeks
um if you're you know really struggling and your health is kind of the precipice and your
had this family vacation plan for a long time then I would take my wife with me um but it can be
a hassle to travel with especially if you're overseas in other countries for the person I know
the person who asked this question I'd say just leave your wife at home that's my suggestion but if
someone else asked this question pretend that they were traveling to other countries like this
I'd still say it's probably better to leave your wife at home if you're going to bring it through
customs each time when you go through to another country um if you're traveling in the United States
and you're you know you're not your health isn't like perfect you're not in full remission
I would say bring your wife with you don't have any issues traveling with it on the airplane domestically
and all um you don't have to tell them anything um domestic travel so but if you're in remission
you're going to on a trip for a week then by all means you can leave your wife at home for a week
some of the right programs say to use a grounding mat so yes a lot of them do don't read what it says
on the right probably you don't have to use a grounding mat with any of the right programs
except the foot bath so the iron growing is what you really should be using a grounding mat because
you got your feet in the water you want to draw those frequencies through your body that's the whole
idea and the frequencies are going to be attracted to the ground to the ground de-bat to what is
ground de-them that's what a ground de-bat is it attaches it to your outlet to the ground
literally the ground the earth outside so um the iron pro wave is really the only thing that you
need to use the grounding mat with you can use the grounding mat we've discussed this at least a
hundred times on these zoom calls about the use of the grounding mat you only need to use it on the
iron pro wave if you're going to use a grounding the grounding sheet in your bed make sure you put it
on the lower half of the bed underneath the fitted sheet on top of the mattress
should I be using it during personal programs and during the night and over no just on the iron pro
wave also I think you said the jackhammer attachment would enable one to be up and about
while still receiving frequencies yes you could if you're using it during the day and you're up and
about but still the treatment range is still only going five to eight feet so if you're beyond that
range it's not really you're not getting a hold on a benefit from it but if you're within five to
eight feet from it the majority of time you are getting benefit so I you know I really like the jackhammer
for that reason we include the jackhammer in our new arrived purchases um but if you purchase it
prior to us including it you can purchase one from true right we don't sell them they don't give
us a discount on it um so you just purchase it right from true right my pirated gland is swallowed the
radiologist told me to use a warm compress on it uh the oncologist told me to go to an ENT to see if
it needs to be drained what do you think I have my onyx research site as I'm pirated tablets but it's
still difficult to do kills because I rely on a feeding tube and crushing them tends to jam that up
um so this person got radiation therapy I believe that's what they're talking about here with the
pirated gland being swallowed um I don't know why they told you to do a warm compress the typically
the thing with swelling you do ice um maybe they're trying to get it to drain you can't do uh cold
and for five minutes then warm for five minutes cold for five minutes warm for five minutes you can
try that to get a pumping action through it that might help um I would try both warm and ice I would
see which one tends to work better for you sometimes heat works better for people and gets things going
sometimes that just causes more swelling so you're just going to have to try those things can have
ice handy to do it uh the side as I'm pirated will just help rebuild the pirated gland it's not going to
really help get rid of any swelling in there and he's concerned if there if there is a pocket of
swelling that needs that could be drained um that's a possibility but I haven't really heard that
I would go I would use the ice and heat first and see if you can get things moving I have found
what I believe to be parasites possibly tapeworms but not certain of the type there are so many
rife parasite programs what would you recommend and how often well like doing any other programming other
than what I program for you um as I've always said you just have to play with it you know doing a parasite
program once or twice isn't going to do anything you know any lasting good you have to do it multiple times
to see if it's even going to work for you I use the parasite all frequencies six hours law which is
a good one to use a couple times with the grounding that involved frost by lore um
belly I need to read of them as quickly as possible the itchyness insane and robbing me of sleep
and might be contributing by ability inability to gain weight I've seen that mood grade
deactivation is earth one to two table spoons in water garlic pyacids pumpkin seeds um can be helpful
for a couple of weeks are these fast and effective a loader together what would you recommend we have a
para um uh clear product that we use um it's our private label a php's vermouth huge which I think is
the best parasite cleanser because it's just it's got so many good parasite killers in there so it'll
kill the the widest array of parasites going through a bottle that shouldn't be enough to kill most
parasites in a person's body typically you could kill parasites fairly quick um doing the parasite
all frequencies is my favorite one than one I would recommend to do I had an MRI last week the last one
was in September or four months on the hormone blockers by tumors and none mass areas have shrunk
about 50 percent it seems consulting with the surgeon next week to get her opinion on my next step
options the week after I've tentatively scheduled a consult with Dr. Simmons to get her second opinion on
surgery along with what she would recommend post surgery as far as treatment I'm not likely to opt
for radiation and I know they will want me to keep uh want to keep me on some kind of horrible
blockers it's likely with all this feedback I will schedule a one I'm going to go to you try to help
figure out my program from there yeah I would um I'm not a big fan of radiation for breast cancer
at all um because you're going through the chest cavity you're going through the heart you're
expecting major artery so I'm not a big fan of radiation for breast cancer the hormone blockers if
they're tolerable um just do work better than you know the natural horrible blocker so if you're
able to tolerate it and they want to keep you on that I wouldn't do too much of a pushback if you see
this good this much of a change I mean that's a great that's a 50 percent reduction is something to
be celebrated I don't want to lose my hair from chemo but a cold cap seems risky with the two
were so near my hairline are there other practices protocol supplements that will help you keep my hair
no not really uh the reason why you lose your hair with chemo is because chemo is going to be attracted
to more rapidly replicating cells instead it's more attracted to the cancer um but there are other
cell lines in your body that's to catch 22 that are more rapidly replicating like your hair follicles
like your immune system so um it's uh you know we've talked about this before that the cold cap kind of
thing is really the only thing that's shown a whole lot of my ability as far as helping people keep
their hair and it's still you know not like that great keep it working either um and um and then you
got to look at your put it your head and a really cold ice is that good for your brain I don't know
maybe it is it's anti-inflammatory maybe but um also the idea of cold therapy during IVs are there other
things to decrease the chance of neuropathy in my hands and feet well you know the neuropathy in your
hands and feet and or their abuse on your body not just your hair follicles after chemo therapy is after
48 hours beach running the high end flow wave every day so that will help hold that out
the neuropathy in your hands and feet was because the the the caustic chemicals of chemotherapy damage
your your peripheral nerves and the the damage of those large ammeter a diameter aprons which
carry pain and um uh tingleed and things are what are damaged and that's why when you get
died for those nerves you end up with neuropathy if cold repels chemo uh might heat draw it
um well cold doesn't repel chemo so uh cold decreases um circulation um and heat will increase
circulation so heads the question you know back here where where the person's talking about
where where it was this one with the swallied at the product land and the person
and the radiologist saying with a warm compress on it i think the radiologist thinking warm
compress try to get low lip blow and haven't get flowing but typically let's say you spray your ankle
what do you do when you spray your ankle you don't you don't um you know put heat on it i mean it would
just blow up like a bloated you just be dieted pain you put ice on it um and the idea is that ice
decreases the inflammation ice will decrease the blood flow because it's the blood flow
to the area that then will leak different cytokines and immune particles to
and histamine that fires this inflammatory reaction so um the idea of using cold is your
decreasing blood flow to the scalp therefore um you're not repelling the chemo but you're decreasing
the circulation the chemo is circulating through your blood vessels so if you could decrease the
circulation to that area you're going to heads decrease the amount of chemo to that area
by the heating paint on my deck during the IVs help pull the chemo to the tumors um it's not
necessary and it might cause swelling so if you're oncologist doesn't recommend that i would
recommend it i've never heard anybody using heat at the side of the cancer to to increase the
circulation to the cancer um i don't think that's what's recommended are there practices protocol
supplements that might help with the impending chemo these symptoms look at our chemo protocol on our
blog post we have a chemo protocol there's nothing that's going to be perfect with any of these
um and every single person is different the whole idea is that you want the chemo to work so
you're staying away from antioxidants um before you do the chemo and for 48 hours after the chemo IV
is finished you're staying away from antioxidants you do a 24 hour water fast so you're only drinking
water for 24 hours prior to the IV of the chemo um what you're done with the chemo you could go
home and eat something and then you're after 48 hours you're hitting the antioxidants you're
doing the ion throw waves you're supporting liver detox pathways look at that seven phases of detox
course and look at how you could support the detox pathways as best as possible that's what's
going to help with all these things all these are side effects that are affected the chemo is affecting
other organs if you could get the chemo to work at the cancer when it really is going to be best
to be working at the cancer which is within the first 48 hours of doing the chemo and then try to
help your body detoxify afterwards is the key i used to do oil pulley but i've gotten out of the habit
so nyru oil pulley that's what you swash um coconut oil or olive oil in your mouth for 10 to 15 minutes
so you spit it out of the sink help pull toxins out of your mouth out of your gums uh it can be very
beneficial but you do not do oil pulley if you have any mercury fillings in your mouth that's
an absolute no no so if you have any mercury fillings any silver fillings in your mouth you do not
do oil pulley that can make you worse systemically worse oh i don't have any uh mercury fillings pretend
well then you could go back to doing oil pulley there's nothing wrong with that
should it be a good systematically as well systemically i think as well as tumor and my throat it can
be good to do oil pulley as long as you don't have any um silver fillings what kind of oil
oil wellness has oil pulley oil designs for health has a new oil oil oil that you can use but you
can use coconut oil you can use olive oil it's a really no secret to what oil use typically coconut oil
or olive oil is what you would use you binders decrease food and supplement effectiveness when
should they be taken uh typically binders don't uh um you know people will argue that binders can
grab on to your minerals which they can um and some people will say don't take binders when you're
taking other you know at the same time you're taking other supplements um there may be some truths
of that it does have some make some sense so you could choose to take binders at different times
of the day that you're not taking your supplements taking them away from other times you're taking
supplements typically i'm not that particular with that i don't think that goes on all that much i don't
think the binders have an affinity towards your nutrients so i don't think that this is much of a
problem uh when i take my Chinese herbs and rife i feel much better without adding the many supplements
soon i will get a cheek swab perhaps you we can simplify the supplements okay that's good do oil
rife machine kill cancer so quickly uh well there really wasn't any way to document what royal rife
did and a lot of the things that he wrote out and did document have been lost so we don't we don't know
how fast um uh the cancer died and everybody is different that's just the truth i mean we've had people
miraculously cured lots of people miraculously cured with the rife and we've had people
and it seemingly did nothing so um everybody is different everybody's gonna respond differently everybody's
body is different everybody's physiology is unique and you just gotta keep moving forward as best
you possibly can what is your opinion about the uh biblesid alpha 1 peptide for the immune system
um i'm not a big fan of using peptide uh therapy um it can stimulate growth and that is why most people
use peptide therapy is because it simulates growth and it stimulates more youthfulness of i've
always shined away from peptide therapy and read several books on peptide therapy it really doesn't
to me make sense for cancer patients another practitioner wants me to start hydrogen peroxide
what are your thoughts with this i'll be starting mistletoe not sure what to do i wrote a blog post
on hydrogen peroxide um that you might want to look to what what you say in other
practitioners want to you to start hydrogen peroxide i i think you're to say that you're doing oral
hydrogen peroxide so hydrogen peroxide uh for uh let me let me share my screen here a second
uh change my screen share real quick um so you can see my screen now this is the blog post hydrogen peroxide
for cancer not so fast um and watch this video that i did on hydrogen peroxide we talked about this
a few weeks ago hydrogen peroxide is H2O2 making it an unstable molecule well that's
the benefit of hydrogen peroxide it's an unstable molecule it will give an oxygen away
it's an it's not an oxygenizing uh product it's an oxidant just like chemotherapy is an oxidant
but hydrogen peroxide is not a stable oxidant so what you do is hydrogen peroxide
orally you're gonna you could kill bacteria if you're gut um well that could be a good thing you're
bad thing because you could actually disrupt your flow around your bacteria how your peroxide's not
gonna be absorbed into your bloodstream and circulate around and go to the cancer and then give
its oxygen to the cancer and oxidate the cancer killing the cancer it's just not gonna do that
just you know so when there's when there's alternative practitioners and practitioners that say use
hydrogen peroxide orally and you know this is where i struggle because you're not understanding
some basic physiology hydrogen peroxide is great as an oxidant an oxidizing agent that will kill
bacteria and viruses topically because it will readily give off that other oxygen which is an
O negative molecule and it will attach to a cell membrane of a bacteria uh and it will kill by
the by the active of uh being a um oxidizing agent to damage the cell membrane and it destroys it
that's what a poison is so that's how chemotherapy works it's a poison it's an oxidizing agent that
is a poison that's how uh hydrogen peroxide is if you drink uh mood grade 35 percent hydrogen peroxide
you could kill yourself that'd be a warning to not gonna take that much we're gonna take a lower dose
well are you really if you're not killing the cancer because it's not stable enough to be
um to travel and be absorbed into the uh through the gut wall into the bloodstream and travel to
the cancer and then give off its oxygen there so it meant to me it makes okay if i had maybe if i had
stomach cancer maybe using you know hydrogen peroxide might be an option um but there's dangers to
that too because it's a toxin so you have to be really careful with that so i even with stomach cancer
i wouldn't recommend it because um there's just too many too many downsides you could you could
kill the patient so i'm not a phantom hydro peroxide so you could read my article about that
there um um i mentioned i used the hpilora program and right right and it started
passing five-inch worms i saved and took it to my doctor he said it looked like a scaris
roundworm oh how fun is that i bought five boxes of your fenbenzole he gave me a script for albenzole
two pills is there a difference you know i know you'd have to google that search that i'm not familiar
i think it's the same product this is just the fenbenzole is the name of the product that is used for
animals uh this is the human form and it's probably a much higher dose that's the difference the
fenbenzole boxes that we sell in our store are for a ten pound dog that is a cancer treatment
that really a parasite treatment even though it's a parasite pill it's an off-label use of that
medication over the counter so we feel free to sell it so that's really the different
does my whole family including the dog need to be treated but really if it is a roundworm
it is really passed through feces in contact with feces hpilora itself is different hpilora is
a roundworm it's on a worm it's on a tapeworm it's small little parasite and it is passed through
oral transmission as well so if you kissed your kids you could pass hpilora so that we're not talking
about hpilora you know so no but in the case of hpilora then yes you do want to work on treating the
whole family putting this family pets but not with roundworm if right is killing them do you still say
it's best to take that fenbenzole make sure they are all gone love to know your thoughts on this
before I start yeah I you know I would not feel bad about taking a medication as well as doing the
parasite program the hpilora program I think this one will take you that doing the pair of clear
you could try that I mean if you're afraid of side effects of this medication that is recommended
because it is much higher dose I'm sure than the fenbenzole boxes you could try just doing
the fenbenzole boxes instead doing a much much lower dose you might have just as good a result
if the worms could go to the brain no I don't think these roundworms could go to the brain I don't
think there's a danger that I think they're mainly just in the plant should I put the knife on the
hand for parasites in case they have gone through no I wouldn't be concerned really with that
would you agree that a cold cap for a head and neck cancer is a bad idea or would it be safe
talk to your oncologist about that I'm not the person really to discuss that they can actually
give you a prescription for that I think too so I think you can get a pain through your insurance so
I wouldn't check on that now back to the parasite they there are parasites that go to your brain you know
I had one patient years ago that had migrates that were happening five days a week
went to Mayo went everywhere she was about ready to jump off a bridge tested her and it actually came
back the parasite that you get from pork and which was really weird I asked her where she could have
gotten it to what she could get anywhere but she ended up doing say to the soul started when she
went to Mexico and ate some street food there we gave her a parasite like I think we gave her
pro-verbal foods at the time since years ago and with it a week her headache went away so it was
pretty crazy in December I had a $500 got Zuma tests through another practitioner that said I had no
parasites I've been using human fed beds all 220 grams milligrams twice a day for months however I
still have parasites yeah I don't know what parasites that you're passing you and I don't know
what fed bed is all what parasites fed bed is all is the best for so if you know the those the
gut the parasite I'm not familiar with the Zuma tests we don't use that lab but I assume this was
a stool sample test and the stool sample tests can miss things too so and your body can change so
if in December you had this test and it was negative you could have picked up the parasite right
after that they reproduce quite quickly so that doesn't really convince me that there's not a problem
and taking this that fed bed is all doesn't convince me that it's going to solve every parasite problem either
you know these are most of the drugs out there are specific to just certain classes of parasites
but that's all they really kill that's why there are so many different medication medications for
different parasites you might want to google the milk cleanse it got rid of my parasites so that's
interesting um and look at that thank you for that insight as well you know there's a not to be
problem oh totally um I just want to throw it in another light of thought there's a whole light of
thought that that parasites are are not necessarily always a bad thing we always think of
having parasites as a bad thing um there is there is actually a company that you could actually buy
capsules that have live parasites in them and you take them in order to create a parasitic infection
because it has been shown through um different studies that people with severe autoimmune diseases
if they're exposed to parasites can actually help calm down the autoimmune disease um so there is
actually a therapy that using parasites to your advantage um in a symbionic relationship and the idea
that um hey parasites um can actually work to our advantage now I know we're all grossed out with
about parasites we want to get rid of parasites the truth is there's a study done a few years ago
that I thought was kind of interesting that said anybody in the northern states they did the study
comparing people in the United States in different areas anybody in northern states I can't
remember what they classified as northern states whether it stayed below freezing for X amount
and months of the year um so people in the northern states they found that 35% of the people they tested
and parasites the people in the southern states um because the the ground doesn't freeze so there's
a greater concentration of parasites um they show that 90% of the people tested at parasites so the
idea is that just because you have a parasite doesn't necessarily mean that you have to work at
getting rid of the parasite or that the parasite is causing you ill health just think about that
a little bit just because the person has a parasite doesn't mean that the parasite or parasites are
the culprits that are causing ill health and I would argue and I talk about this in the auto
immune course that it is really the problem really comes in with parasites is when you've actually
created antibodies to the parasites when you create antibodies to the pathogen that's when you have
a problem it's not the path it's so much the pathogen itself just like you go up and you get mosquito
bites oh I got a mosquito bite it inches for a couple minutes or a day and it's gone because I
don't have antibodies to that venom of the mosquito then I don't have really much of a problem with it
it's when you have antibodies to that thing that it really causes health issues just another
point of view not to be such a contrarian but it's something to think about do you have any idea why
hot flashes are worse at night well hot flashes are caused from a sudden
down regulation of estrogen that's what hot flashes are so when you have your estrogen and a balance
that it just drops that's when you get this hot flash so when you have these bumps up and down
of estrogen as a person's going through a beta cause or a person's normal blocking pill that's what
are that's what it's causing at hot flashes I've asked both my ecologist and either no
any guesses it's really that's that is the etiology of a hot flash so I'm not sure what I'll do
about the horrible blockers because my sleep is wrecked and as I said last week I think it is
raising my glucose level that can't be healthy and also concerned about long-term cardiac and
bone health we'll see what they say and we'll figure it out yes I do I am very impressed 50%
reduction of your tumors so that's really exciting I think they might be tapeworms you know what
the ill-treated tapeworms where they start to promote your bottom this is really gross that you're
supposed to grab them very carefully and slowly talk them and put them wrapped them around the
pencil and you slowly wide them up because the head of the tapeworm which is the last thing to come
out and reproduce more and more pieces of a tapeworm so you want to get the head out so you have to go
very slow and wrap them around the pencil and you roll them up just what you want to do here
but do you know why sudden drops of estrogen occur at night it's probably because it has
to do with your circadian rhythm of your normal estrogen you're when you're taking an estrogen
blocker you're not removing you're you know you're not going in and surgically removing your ovaries so
that you don't have anything creating estrogens your ovaries are trying to kick in remember your
hormones are released on both a circadian rhythm and their release released on a negative feedback loop
so a circadian rhythm is when you have this normal flow of different times of the day where you
release your hormones like for instance thyroid hormone is released in the morning and it
tapers off during the night and it's typically T4 and T3 that is released in mainly T490 percent
that it's converted and it got to T3 same thing with your estrogen and progesterone it's released
at different times the day depending upon your cycle even if you're not cycling anymore so
it will still change throughout the month how it's released when you still have your ovaries add
your other estrogen blocking pill you're still going to get some spikes of estrogen and then the
estrogen blocking pill is going to pull it out of you and it's going to drop so it really has to do
it's your rhythm you're probably getting more of a release of estrogen at night and it's pulled out
so you're getting a spike downward or a sudden drop in estrogen and that's what's causing your issues
at night that would be my guess what I've seen are about an inch long and there are multiple ones
I've sent a photo to you in an email I have extreme rectal itchy which you can do the other
medical treatment or identify a parasite as you have to use some clear tape and you have to put
some tape under your rectum and many times you will do this at night and you'll go in at night to put
tape on your rectum and pull it off and hopefully you'll have some of the eggs or pieces of the
parasite that then can be identified through a parasitologist under a microscope and identify
what type of parasite it is so parasites an inch long that you know unless you're getting just
pieces of a tapeworm or something a tapeworms are very long but checking blood glucose levels is this
random or between meals or fasting I'll go back to the member site and the home page of the
member site it states a fasting morning reading of one's glucose levels can be a great indication
that a cancer is not being fed through goblin up sugar so if you could keep your glucose levels down
everybody's cancer is going to have it's going to be fed by glucose to some degree why because
every cell uses glycolysis in order to make ATP so ATP is your main energy source for every cell
function including muscle function and everything else so keep in your blood glucose levels as
low as possible is a benefit to everybody with cancer and like I said before even if you don't have
cancer so we want to set a goal to get our fasted like a 10 or 12 hour fast fasted go
blood glucose down to 70 fiber last uh that's a pretty handsome goal and most of you won't be able to
accomplish that goal um but that's a goal I mean you have to have a goal that's hard to match or
it's not really a goal and so it's best measured by taking your morning first morning reading when you
wake up before you eat anything or drink anything with a glucometer such as this you could buy a
bit target or a wild barter or something like that uh this is one that's on um Amazon and I
games of like your observance a hundred of these test strips so take your fasted morning reading
and record it on this chart you can download that chart on the member site you can do it daily your
figure starts to get sore and your blood sugar is kind of stayed at a same level every day then you
could no wait take it every three days or whatever down to weekly your goal is to get it down you know
it's reasonable how do I know uh if I need to do a gallbladder cleanse is the apple juice a
concern due to high sugar content honestly do you know with everything you have going on right now
do it a gallbladder cleanse should be the the back burner that's not something that you should
honestly don't I be concerned with at all what is the address to send all by blood work and photos to
how we send your stuff to labs l-a-b-s at cutters clinic or info at cutters clinic and whoever cutters
is spelled e-r-s info at cutters clinic or labs at cutters clinic and wherever all that information is
on the member site or go to the member site then you can look at the lab section and send it to the
labs there all right we'll finish up today soon call thanks for being on know that I've prayed for
you all and hang in there and be patient to the Lord we trusted him and all things be prayed you know
for wisdom and knowledge and peace that passes all understanding and trust him for the outcome of
everything you're doing because he is your healer he is your stator of life and he needs to be the one
that you are relying on all right bye bye